un julia roumanie j'ai 38 ans je suis
cadre dans le milieu de l'assurance
depuis
bientôt une quinzaine d'années je suis
donc conseillère départementale du
canton 4 qui regroupe donc fin que tu
than toute la ville de sainte-suzanne et
deux quartiers de saint-andré qui sont
petit bazar et cambuston
je suis particulièrement attaché à ce
canton parce que c'est usain mes grands
parents ils sont nés ma mère il y est né
j'ai toujours de la famille là-bas donc
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs d'enfance
saint-andré j'y suis né mes parents mon
père y est née tout là ma famille
paternelle il est né donc j'ai également
la plupart de mes souvenirs toutes mes
plus belles expériences et aujourd'hui
je vis encore dans ce canton que donc
j'y suis particulièrement attachée
effectivement
les actions prioritaires pour moi
aujourd'hui
je fais de la politique de manière très
terre à terre et je me dis qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une multitude de dispositifs
qui existent déjà avec très peu de
moyens on peut aujourd'hui faire
beaucoup de choses mais j'ai
l'impression que ça manque un peu
déficient et de réactivité donc si on
peut faire le lien nous entre le terrain
et les dispositifs qui existent déjà
pour les faire fonctionner au mieux et
surtout plus rapidement
ça fera en tout cas la priorité de ce
mandat voilà
dans les compétences en tout cas le
public visé par le conseil départemental
je reconnais toutes les actions que je
mène en tant que militante puis en tant
que politicienne aujourd'hui c'est à
dire les personnes âgées la femme
l'enfance donc forcément s'il ya un
mandat qui me correspondait en fonction
des actions en tout cas que j'ai mené
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était le mandat de
conseiller départemental